hi top way through the year yours hop
over the sand keeps falling we're all
getting older let's talk about video I
am gay m'dear will be happening six
months from now maybe five I don't know
I forgot it all works sorry December
right yeah yeah we got a bunch of games
coming out between now and then we'll
talk about that later mm-hmm but I
thought it would be fun and entertaining
since we have the reviews editor
gamespot com here and also this guy Mike
who reviews games and editor to talk
about some of the games that came out
earlier and sort of gauge where we are
with you know yeah Game of the Year
contenders yeah and why not so I was
looking to list you shared you did what
did you think it'll is I missing normal
entries what yes perhaps intentionally
ah ok so let's get right down to it
first of all a game we gave ten at a ten
uncharted 4 yeah fourth uncharted game
who reviewed this bad boy oh that was me
who was you Michael yeah all right one
of the best games in 2016 yeah so far I
like it a lot i don't i don't know i
think about the main thing i love about
is how everything about it coalesce is
to create this like really cohesive
amazing experience between the writing
and the dialogue and the characters the
gameplay itself i think was great but i
think what makes it so good is that it
goes back and corrects a lot of mistakes
that the trilogy made then made it kind
of such a renowned series i guess and
problems I had with the series going
through it i think for actually not only
address problems it had gameplay wise
mechanically and thematically but it
also looked at like nathan drake himself
and there's actually one the more
interesting like I know this sounds way
too academic but like the character
studies but it's also it was also just
the spectacle everything like that chase
scene in Madagascar through the
marketplace mud the beginning the
opening boat sequences some people had
mixed feelings about i think that
actually works well kinda in da recipe
ending the ending was tremendous was
great handle two hours oh yeah it's it
also just it kind of sets up the first
three games in a way if you like haven't
played in the games I play for and then
go back in a weird way it kind of sets
it up as like these legends that they
talk about but uh totally
as somebody who barely like I played two
and I played half of three yeah so I
wasn't like deep in it and I sure did a
great job of filling in all those cops
yeah and just like I mean it's gorgeous
which isn't like usually my main
takeaway from games but it really is I
think just it doesn't have any weak
aspects to it my opinion at all the few
points where actually was kind of fella
was dragging it was actually still kind
of integral like these characters we had
these incidental conversations that
became pretty integral later on yeah and
I which I didn't expect and how the
relationships play out i think is
actually really satisfying it's a fan of
the series i think they tied it off
really well I could not have asked for a
better finale but also you know just
like I think naughty dog did a lot of
things better here than they did with
the last of us which previously I
thought was their best game yeah totally
I've read one of the best action games
I've ever could like just in terms of
the combat and I've controlled and you
know move movement within the arenas and
stuff was so much fun Peter talked about
I'm of the game which has great movement
on great shooting which she reviewed
much more recently doom yeah what a
pleasant surprise that one was to you I
did not see him coming I'm not sending
an early review copies man must be PC
trash I was that one discussion no I was
an IP while all that was going on he was
playing it at his desk and I went over
and was like I was doing when you were
like pretty good yeah his eyes are
bleeding it's good did you like they had
the e3 demo they showed off when the
game was announced like did not leave me
interested at all in the game at all I
thought I will not care about this doom
is over as far as I'm concerned and now
I feel like doom has a better future
than it probably ever had hmm the game
is just it's it's such a pure experience
that just gets your heart racing and you
know and it's and it's spectacular to
look at as well some of the environments
although I wish they were more varied
some of the stuff that's in there
especially in hell is just like really
wonderful set pieces yeah a definite
surprise yeah I had never thought that
we'd be talking about two in July and
saying like it's like a genuine game
with you contender it's absolutely one
of the best for it was one of these
things where like 10 minutes in I was
like all right that was a you guys know
what you're doing already because that's
intro chapter was like very self-aware
about like the
waste that comes would do yeah and the
sort of the fact that they were like so
self-aware and so like lice on the like
playing up the sort of lure aspect of
the game and also being like we're not
gonna don't worry it's not doom 3 we're
like I spent 30 minutes setting this up
before you shoot somebody you know
pushes the screen away and as the more I
played the more I was like I was so
reticent to believe that this was good
yeah I was like this can't be good write
it like nothing about or like his my
Cajun off like totally is my
interpretation of this just like weird
like is this nostalgia tation so loaded
now a game that's actually like mediocre
I'm enjoying right but it's [ __ ]
great like it like it's so like up until
the final boss fight i guess i'm so
burnt down a first preserved it open to
the final boss fight like and that then
i was amazing and i literally was like
I'm gonna play you again in a couple
weeks like yeah and I'm super stoked to
see that they've added the whole the
weapon positioning I come in the shot
where it just sticks the gun right in
the middle that's definitely nostalgia
play a trick on me but you know i love
that i really want to see what they're
doing for dlc i hope there's some coming
mmm the multiplayer stuff i don't really
care about snap map is kind of
interesting but it's even with the
sorted list based on popularity it's
hard to really figure out what the great
snap map stuff is the user created stuff
yeah but man if they can do some cool
stuff with dlc like i will be playing
that game again and it's it's when you
think about game of the year right games
like uncharted games or sre games like
doom and like I guess overwatch which
will probably talk about soon i assume
is you know people have the same
positive opinion there's very few
dissenters or wires when it comes to how
they feel about it but when you talk
about a game like uncharted ya got a 10
but a lot of people are like man it's a
great game but it's just not that for me
yeah so I feel like doom is one of these
stronger contenders let's let's talk
about overwatch actually ok let's do it
yeah who reviewed this mic again alright
this is working there pretty good ah you
enjoyed overwatch I mean the whole
office enjoys over Russia playing the
[ __ ] up yeah nice i mean for the a lot
of the same reason i mean like not to
linger on doom too long doom is like
right up there with rocket League like
resogun and that they are some of it's
one of the best feeling games i played
right like so long uh overwatch the same
thing you mean the game is different for
everyone almost like kind of different
than doom it's everyone who jumps into
it yeah it's pretty universally positive
i would say
but you know you jump in as genji and
it's a different game than if you're
playing as Arya who my favorite
character is if you jump in its Lucio
you're looking at the game itself and
through a whole different lens you're
looking at it through a different scope
there's different scale to the fights
because you want to keep different
distances based on different characters
it's like this amalgamation of like all
these shooter tropes but you know you
want to say let's like the kitchen sink
approach they went for everything they
did but it all works in this game
somehow it's like they managed to take
like these Universal arc types from
shooters across the genre and that from
my n across like the decades pretty much
like they took theirs but you know you
got like Farrah who's very much like a
quake kind of like arena-style shooter
character then you have McCree use much
more precise and you have you know
widow-makers a counter-strike ish
character and it's somehow these all
coalesce into this one like like I said
cohesive kind of really good feeling and
very dynamic experience sites I don't
know it's every time I jump into a match
it's somehow still different and I've
been playing it for how many months now
and I don't see myself slowing down too
much yeah like doom doom is the best
campaign a fade mirrors over watches
best online shooter I played and
donkey's years as well what do you think
donkeys ears I just don't can't think
sure you use that phrase differently
every time I haven't played bunch over
watch it I really can't talk about it
cool yeah thanks me I wish I could say I
mean we've talked about overwatch enough
here all night out gamespot com I feel
like it's 21 videos yeah it doesn't
really well but I need to play that game
though like a question that's fell a
different gap then uh actually it's your
mind out of the gutter one that you
wanted I didn't say it my can I can give
it I'll pass on you if you're gonna
start laughing okay XCOM 200-mile talk
about this Ribery fav through review
that overlooked who to view to do you
review everything no I do a lot of stuff
I just I just really liked enemy Unknown
so I volunteered for this one thanks
auntie was kind of overlooked I think so
and you'd like to say maybe it's because
it's not unlike consoles but there's a
heap obviously pc crowd is nothing to i
mean it's probably the first one didn't
sell well on consoles right why they
went for pc only this time around
Waimate know it's coming to call its
calm with consoles it is now which
actually gives me some hope that maybe
it'll tap into a new crowd that
previously overlooked it yeah i mean
like they said from the beginning
they're creating the game would not
exist is now
if they didn't just focus completely on
pc right i mean it feels great it's it's
everything i want from a sequel ism i'm
a take away from it it took the depth in
the creativity of the first sex calm and
just kind of that blend of the
overarching strategy of like scientific
research and base building and then
somehow still tapped into that
turn-based tactical combat that you know
you think about when you think of this
game just between how the different
classes interact await the odds are
stacked against you the entire time but
yet as soon as I fail to campaign or got
to the point where like this is hopeless
and a lot of times you have to do that
you go back and you start new campaign
and it's different enough each time that
you're you still feel like you're making
progress even when things are like just
really shitty yeah i mean just and then
the there's a new dlc out now or I think
it's out I played I don't i recently for
a previous Shen's last gift it adds like
these robots which are essentially like
a new class so you have like the six
classes now that you can play as and
assuming the console will come with
those classes i'm not positive but
between like the map design like how
despite the fact that you might know
you're probably gonna lose it's still
fun as hell from yeah like campaign to
campaign yeah super fun game really
enjoyed it i just checked steam to see
if it was in the sales but it's not at
the moment so still 60 bucks but worth
every penny I still think yeah let's
jump through a couple of these ones at
dark souls 3 you wants talk about that I
don't know who reviewed it I got some
big I got a lot of hate for this review
to give an eight I thought it was a
great game doesn't ring that's true I
guess I'm saying that dark souls phones
are unreasonably fashion yeah I used to
count myself among I still do um but I
you know like I had those reviewing the
game but and I it still will probably be
my top five at the end of the year I
mean even looking ahead our steam sales
are over actually right now sorry my bad
I'm did not realize that yeah but still
a fine game yeah i mean my main takeaway
maybe not my main takeaway but in terms
of negatives I feel like they really got
tired like tired toward the end of it
like this this is a you know Miyazaki
wasn't completely attached to dark souls
2 and a lot of people look at that as
the week entering the series um I still
like Dark Souls 1 the most and then
probably demon's souls and then 3 so 3 3
is still a great game I think just in
comparison to what
you've seen from studio from software do
before the boss isn't this a lot of
times where you would fight a boss later
on the felt recycled you like okay the
old king is pretty much just someone I
fought earlier on yes and I can then
you'd fight champion Gandhi rats I had X
Gandhi obviously that's the whole point
but it was still like the momentum with
the level design like the way it's like
the the verticality of it folds in on
itself and you still like discovering a
shortcut is just as rewarding as
empowering as killing a boss and no
matter how we're talking about fury
earlier which is like a lot of boss
fights and a lot of frustration but at
the same time Dark Souls 3 is very dark
souls esque and no it's uh despite the
fact that you're losing to these bosses
time and time again it's gonna be it's
satisfying moment a moment and like you
feel you're so you're rewarded and you
know like despite the fact that you
might fighting be fighting recycle
bosses later it's still such an
empowering experience to really feel
like you came out that game like more
skilled than you went in like by far
certainly a contender I was flicking
through some of the games here checking
our reviews to see if all of them were
reviewed by Mike there are the next to I
looked up we're both review I'm actually
gonna jump at two one that I know you
reviewed Peter no no I said don't worry
about it it's all good March 10th you
guess what I always review the game
March 10 yeah it was hit man yes it was
and that was the first episode I
reviewed yes yes what do you think of
him out he played the subsequent
episodes I played up until episode 3
evilly revered never heard from guard
over the first two episodes I'm gonna
wait until the full game comes out and
review that yeah cuz when i played
episode 3 I beat it in less than an hour
right and now hitman is a game that you
can go back in and you can mix up the
way you compare the sleeve replayable
Peter right but it's in my opinion it's
not it's not good enough to inspire that
kind of repetition right um you know
specifically the third episode just to
give you an example of how cut and dry
this game can be like I was in Marrakech
this bustling city that's got a huge
market there's a huge protest going on
there's all these military everywhere
and you think oh man it's gonna be
really hard for me to accomplish my goal
so I'm surveying the area walk down the
street some girl is talking to some guy
there's a little icon above their head
this is hey you should pay attention to
this and I listen he's like oh yeah my
dad's I got the key to the city or
whatever but he's all retired but he's
still upstairs I guess okay so i walked
between them go upstairs the dad is
sitting by himself so i did murder him
take the key go downstairs find a
military guy who started out of it and i
take his his uniform yeah so then I
decide okay I'm gonna walk into the
military complex walk right through the
protest into the military thing
essentially I over here another thing
weird like this guys getting a massage
in about half hour I'm like oh that's my
target ok so i find the masseuse knock
him out take his shirt find the guy give
him massage choke him out massage still
gave him the massage oh yeah I'm not
unfair you're not an animal relaxing
before you slit his throat the job oh
you're so tight yeah anyway there are
multiple ways I could have gone about
that many ways that are more difficult
and are entering and then challenging
but why would I like that's the whole
thing right is that like there are so
many ways of doing this and like then
they have all the different challenges
which like take control away from you
around give you more restrictions and
hit man is not a game that is inherently
fun to play it is meant to be a mentally
challenging game so when you have these
solutions handed to you right going back
to do something that isn't fun when
there are lots of other games out there
waiting for your attention it just
doesn't it's not really a thing that is
inspiring just want to do that it's been
interesting i feel like the chapter
based like release of this has benefited
us because i'm not getting burned out on
it as fast as I think I would it was
just like a full game i probably would
have played half than I mean like
they're soft and so that's been
interesting but yeah we'll have to see
looking forward to the review later this
year of the full project and let's burn
through a couple of these because we run
a bit long yeah and Michael Hardy you
reviewed some games Far Cry primal which
think of it uh it was surprised me i
like how much it makes use of its
setting i think being like a prehistoric
and I prehistoric kinda like Stone Age
setting they could've easily if I had
like oh this machine gun sling shot but
no they stuck to it was your like Spears
bow and arrow if you play it on the new
survival mode it's actually makes like
really tense the entire time through
with Sun falls like the Predators come
out yeah it really it's one of the
better uses of like a setting it's not
realistic at all but it's
I'm really like when I think of games
that kind of took these aesthetics and
took these like these tropes at that
time and made good use of it for fun
gameplay i think i forgot panels like a
standout super surprised by how much
have fun it was and have not a reskin it
was yeah it's it's still got all the
Ubisoft sort of tropes but it's really
good rigo fun ah the witness you also
reviewed that right yeah that one that
one that was one of the more challenging
games I've played I know a lot of people
have didn't have a hard time with it but
I mean it's a challenging game I think
universally but the way that it
communicates its ideas to you so subtly
it doesn't doesn't hold your hand at all
you just go you're on this island you go
explore you can if you want to go right
to like there's not really a there is a
last puzzle but you know you need to
like activate these lasers around the
island you can go to one some of the
more difficult puzzles and if you know
how to do it it's like it's like I don't
know you if you spend like three weeks
reading a textbook you're gonna be
you're gonna know something about like
basic chemistry yeah but if you just try
to take a test right the beginning of
like the semester before you read a book
you're not gonna be able to do it but
this not to be too i could democratic
yeah sound like such a I don't know
tonight yeah the way this game teaches
you its ideas like in such a way that
you actually learn its systems and how
like they interact is so good it's such
a the puzzles themselves you seem like
how can you just have these mazes and
move these dots run amazed how can that
be a whole game yeah then the people
played it like oh my god I know what
this square mean it's like burn in my
head that if to separate these from
those and like the shape means totally
you have to like fail this on purpose I
don't that it's really crazy I've still
not completed it I feel like I'm about
75% of the way through and I'm terrified
Madeleine lost the knowledge on it and
at the same time you could go back to a
puzzle you there's a chance you go back
to a puzzle that was killing you for
days Ron you'd solve it right now god I
need to jump back gorgeous looking game
at Peter brand new review street fighter
5 earlier this year obviously they
promised a lot of fixes and updates
throughout the rest of the year is
ranting about what they've done so far
that makes you feel like SF 5 is in a
better place than it was no I don't
think so any of the game is a really
strong core in terms of like a fighting
system I know that there's some people
who have some misgivings based on what
was changed from street fighter 4 but
really it's a very sound fighting game
the problem with the model that they've
adopted is one that is you
we're sort of gonna give you little
appetizers like along the way and the
full course will be available you know
after a certain amount of time but it's
just the way that they've handled this
game is a problem but beyond that the
game itself is so easy to walk away from
it's not it doesn't have that infectious
spirit that a lot of pass through
fighter games had because there's just
so little to it and the modes that they
have put in there outside of just online
competitive matches are really poorly
done so it's a great game that that just
wasn't given the treatment it deserved
yeah we got a couple more games here I
want to cut away from the gameplay will
put our hands I will do the thing we did
at e3 with like thumbs up thumbs down
thumbs middle and I put your hand down
if you haven't played it okay all right
all right so put your hands out first
game that comes through is fire watch
actually gonna play that down in terms
of a game of the Year contender yeah um
I don't like it as much no no that was
all right yeah okay ah super hot oh well
actually gave me the your conduct I came
even I came to York again just like d
really good good this is good yeah yeah
I'll give it a good yeah I feel like I'm
I think I did give it a good yeah like a
literature review de already inside so
plated okay play inside is pretty good
ah quantum break unless you count the
two lodging today and play it no I yeah
not a fan of quantum break me and Peter
second or cups I'm with you bro I don't
know what I don't know I don't know what
the impressed you never smoked in that
week and unravel none of us played it
yeah all right okay fair enough and I
think that's everything I've got written
down here is anything you guys were
thinking of thought I haven't touched I
would like to mention offworld trading
company uh uh it's kind of a homicide
it's not have a niche game right it's
RTS but it's there's no like military
there's no combat involved it's all
economics is if you took like the
economics from a game like civilization
or I mean like even if you took it from
Starcraft and blew it up and make it
much more complicated in a really fun
way and there's always something to be
doing worrying about how this resource
is gonna affect your stock price and
you're trying to buy out the enemy just
felt like monopoly it sounds like drug
wars it's both of those I guess if you
when monopoly means drug wars you offer
old trading company so try to check that
out even if you're not an RTS fan
there's a few people in the office that
we played it and I mean I think a few
more pleasantly surprised yeah alright
what we think Peter hyper light drifter
all right I game I still need to play
more of but does the hour so I did play
was amazing and it's got amazing reviews
as well so I feel like where people
should play that what about mighty
number 9 don't do that it came is okay
all right all there is to apparently
there was a red something with weekend
of ash the Kickstarter sort of total for
video games this year is pretty down
previous what board games apparently are
super super up cool yeah they're back
yeah just inhale ah got some sort of
bejeweled board game yeah hey I don't
know who the [ __ ] thought that was good
idea he just gave it to me when I was
talking to him he kept like you know
like someone holding something to her
you're wondering why they're doing that
don't want that well those are our picks
so far for game of year 2016 yeah let us
know what you think should win so far in
the comments below
you